chers amis aujourd'hui je m'adresse de
nouveau à tous les citoyens de Russie
il ne s'était pas exprimé sur le sujet
depuis la fin de la mutinerie samedi
Vladimir Poutine a rompu le silence une
intervention courte dans laquelle il
prend soin de ne pas citer le nom Dave
Gayne prigogne il s'adresse au
combattant du groupe paramilitaire
Wagner et leur propose trois portes de
sortie
aujourd'hui vous avez la possibilité de
continuer votre service pour la Russie
en signant un contrat avec le ministère
de la Défense ou d'autres structures
militaires et de sécurité ou de
retourner à vos familles et proches ceux
qui le souhaitent peuvent partir pour la
Biélorussie la promesse que j'ai faite
sera tenue
le président russe dit aussi avoir évité
un bain de sang orchestré toujours selon
lui par l'Occident et l'Ukraine
ils ont essayé de les utiliser dans
l'ombre contre leur frère d'armes avec
lesquels ils se sont battus ensemble
pour le bien du pays et de son avenir
c'est pourquoi dès le début des
événements sur mes instructions directes
des mesures ont été prises pour éviter
une grande effusion de sang
s'en est suivi une réunion avec les
principaux responsables de la sécurité
russe avec notamment en Sergi shoyungu
le ministre de la Défense une réunion
pour montrer que la situation est sous
contrôle et pour donner l'image d'un
retour à la normale
impossible pour Vladimir Poutine de ne
pas prendre la parole car 2 heures plus
tôt
c'est le chef du groupe Wagner qui
réapparaissait enfin seulement le son de
sa voix
l'objectif de la révolte était de sauver
notre groupe Wagner
et non pas de renverser le pouvoir russe
lui aussi ne s'était pas manifesté
depuis la mutinerie un long message
audio de 11 minutes où il raconte que
ces hommes refusaient d'être intégrés à
l'armée russe ce qu'exigeait le Kremlin
il commente aussi sa chevaucher vers
Moscou sans être arrêté par l'armée
russe
a illustré les énormes problèmes de
sécurité dans ce pays une inconnue
subsiste rien dans le message ne permet
de dire où se trouve evegaini Prigogine
ni même d'attester formellement qu'il
s'agit bien de savoir